cette vidéo est le premier pas dans
l'univers dc sur la chaîne et quoi de
mieux que le sneijder kuyt sorti
récemment pour introduire le sujet
néanmoins cela ne va pas être chose
facile
a contrario du marvel cinématiques
univers ce don traitons déjà depuis un
bon bout de temps et bien l'univers du
dc où est beaucoup plus complexe de par
les choix de warner bros que ce soit sur
l'aspect financier marketing créatifs
commercial etc etc alors je ne dis pas
que ce sont des choses que l'on ne
retrouve pas chez marvel évidemment mais
ce sont des aspects qui joue un rôle
assez majeur dans le développement de
l'univers de dc comics et cela joue un
petit peu trop d'ailleurs moment warner
n'étant pas un studio dédié à l'univers
des super-héros nous devons faire face
par moments bas des échecs cuisants
suite à des choix plutôt étonnant mais
aussi des grands succès 1 qui appelle à
des suites ou bas des reboot avec des
vision créative etc etc donc voilà on ne
va pas trop s'étendre sur tout ça sachez
juste que l'avenir est indécis
concernant cet univers et nous sommes à
la fois hyper libre pour imaginer plein
de choses mais à la fois hyper restreint
bref je vous propose ma vision avec
trois théories et août et bah j'espère
que cela vous plaira
[Musique]
nous sommes face à un drôle de carrefour
et ça colle bien avec le thème de la
théorie le sneijder kuyt est née d'une
forte demande des fans de voir la
version originelle prévu de just is
league
imaginez donc par zack snyder sauf que
c'est une version qui n'a jamais été
prévu et approuvé par warner bros qui
sont les véritables patrons derrière
l'univers du dissimule ce qui
logiquement vous vous en doutez et veut
dire que le sneijder que tu n'es pas
canon à la timeline aussi bon soit-il
évidemment je ne mets pas que si cette
version cartonne warner pourrait changer
ses plans et rendrer cette version
officielle
néanmoins ce n'est pas le cas pour le
moment et il y a très peu de chances que
ce soit à l'avenir la majorité du public
a déjà vu justice league au cinéma en
2017 et ça s'arrête là
le sneijder kuyt se dirigent plus
facilement vers un public de niche donc
les fans de dc mais mais mais mais mais
il existe peut être une alternative
grâce à une suite officielle de la
timeline prévue pour 2022
je parle bien évidemment de zee flash
que vous soyez un expert ou non de 10 si
vous avez été tous témoins des capacités
de flash dans le sinaï de requêtes et ce
n'est pas un pouvoir qui sort de nulle
part le fait de pouvoir atteindre la
vitesse de la lumière et même voyager
dans le temps
tout ça ça vient des comics et je dirais
même que c'est une caractéristique qui
symbolise le personnage et qui le sépare
des autres héros qui courent vite par
rapport à son film solo 2022
les informations que nous possédons à ce
sujet caresse l'idée que barry allen
tenterait de voyager dans le temps grâce
à son pouvoir pour sauver sa mère de son
assassinat
un assassinat qui conduira le père de
bari en prison alors qu'il est innocent
dans cette démarche d'amener le voyage
dans le temps dans la timeline principal
et l'idée que warner bros n'a pas fait
l'effort de proposer le sneijder kuyt
simplement dans le vent car pour le
moment le film semble être produit pour
du beurre en quelque sorte
et bien tout pourrait être calculé afin
d'amener le multivers et les nombreuses
réalités en rectifiant l'erreur de
parcours de warner bros concernant
justice league
il possède le moyen de retourner cette
erreur en quelque chose de calculé par
rapport au futur de la saga grâce aux
fines de ce flash rendant donc à la fois
le film justice league de 2017 et le
sneijder kuyt cohérent à l'univers et
canon et pour aller encore plus loin ce
flash pourrait permettre d'accentuer
tout ce côté réalité en étant le
déclencheur d'une ligne parallèle à la
trame principale que soit instauré
warner bros
c'est quelque chose qui arrive plusieurs
fois dans les comics les voyages dans le
temps de paris ne sont pas sans
conséquences
nous pouvons prendre pour exemple le cas
du sneijder kuyt où il pourrait exister
une réalité où justement baril n'est pas
arrivé à temps pour aider sai borg a
séparé les mother box et donc la mort
des super héros que l'on connaît
laissant la porte ouverte à dark side
alors en voulant sauver sa mère dans le
passé et donc changer le cours de
l'histoire
barry aurait pu créer une nouvelle ligne
temporelle
une réalité où l'histoire du sneijder
kuyt a existé un simple battement d'aile
d'un papillon peut créer la plus
dévastatrice des tornades
l'équation anti vie qu'est ce que c'est
que ce bordel
rien de méchant ou de négatif avec ça je
sais que ça existe dans les comics
depuis très longtemps mais c'est un
concept si abstrait que c'est d'une
complexité à définir et à intégrer pour
des films de super héros
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
développer un univers en comics c'est
très différent des films un comics peut
s'étaler en plusieurs comics nous
montrer les pensées des protagonistes
amener des personnages totalement hors
du commun
alors qu'un film déjà cela se veut être
assez accéléré genre deux heures voire
quatre heures comme le sneijder kuyt
mais surtout il faut que cela concorde
avec l'univers instauré c'est à dire
notre société notre réalité est que cela
soit cohérent avec les règles et les
valeurs de la galaxie c'est là la force
des films de super héros qui s'adapte à
nos lois universelles
donc c'est là la problématique
l'équation anti vie c'est un petit peu
trop fantastique et abstrait pour le dc
ue je trouve personnellement ce qui va
certainement d'après moi être remanié
pour l'univers mais c'est quelque chose
que je dis juste comme ça
bref déjà qu'est ce que nous savons dark
side est en quête depuis toujours de
l'équation anti vie une équation qui
dans l'idée d'un remaniement n'a pas été
définie par le premier film justice
league ni le sneijder kuyt malgré ses
quatre heures pour justement laisser le
champ libre à warner pour une
potentielle suite des événements et
c'est très important de le souligner
steppenwolf aurait eu une vision
provoquée par les mots the box lui
montrant que l'équation anti vie se
trouvait sur terre d'où l'intérêt de
darkseid pour la planète une petite
facilités scénaristiques
mais tout à fait cohérente et bien
pensés pour amener la problématique de
l'équation
ce qu'on peut supposer du coup et que
l'équation anti vie est en quelque sorte
liée aux moteurs boxe grâce à la vision
et de par sa présence sur terre cela
souligne le fait que déjà c'est quelque
chose de très anciens qui repose depuis
la nuit des temps sur la terre donc
possiblement en rapport avec des
anciennes tribus et surtout que la
justice league possèdent donc une avance
sur dark side concernant son obtention
de suppositions existent pour moi tout
d'abord dans une cohérence scénaristique
et la construction d'un film basic de
super héros l'équation anti vie serait
le mcg fine du projet donc en gros
l'objet entre guillemets qui sert à
l'intrigué principale et qui intéressent
à la fois nos héros et leurs ennemis
donc nos héros pourrait être à la
recherche de l'équation avec le compte à
rebours de l'arrivée de dark side sur
terre une fois cette équation trouvait
elle pourrait être retournée contre dark
side à la manière de thanos avec les
pierre d'infini et en possession dé
mother box est accompagné de sai borg
qui peut les comprendre des manipulés ce
dernier serait le héros qui pourraient
découvrir cette équation cependant
deuxième suppositions liée à la première
je ne peux m'empêcher de penser que l'ex
l'autor or reviendra et en définit comme
l'un des antagonistes ultime de superman
et surtout l'homme le plus intelligent
du monde il pourrait être le seul à
comprendre et déchiffrer l'équation anti
vie est dans un délire ultime de vouloir
faire tomber superman ce serait pour lui
un moyen de pactiser avec dark side à
part s'il décide de se retourner et de
sauver la terre
mais bon cela reste des petites idées
comme ça dans tous les cas de l'alliance
de l'auteur avec dark side pourrait
faire écho à la scène de justin league
où nous voyons luthor justement avec
wolf
j'aimerais pour finir vous partager une
petite idée qui m'est venue à la suite
du slider cut
à l'origine les mother box sont trois
artefacts d'origine
apocalypse tienne c'est à dire qu'elles
ont été conçues sur apocalypse la
planète de darkseid dans le but de
conquérir d'autres planètes
une fois réunis elles forment l'unité et
theraform la planète pour la rendre
comme apocalypse une planète de
désolation et de lave ou les habitants
deviennent les serviteurs de darkseid
les paras démo est ce que ce
fonctionnement ne se rapprocherait pas
de l'équation anti vie par le biais de
la vision montrer à stephan wolf et leur
pouvoir les mother box semblent être
liés à l'équation anti vie comme vu
auparavant
cependant étant indépendante est capable
de réagir aux émotions à ce qui les
entoure et agir dans leur intérêt les
mother box pourrait être une des
réponses à l'équation de vie et je ne
parle pas de l'équation anti vie mais
bel et bien celle de vie tout d'abord la
première bataille opposant la terre à
dark side les boîtes mer sont censés
pouvoir terraformer la planète et c'est
ce qui se passe le champ de bataille
devient a lieu de désolation de la lave
apparaît etc
sauf que ce lieu refleurira avec le
temps ce qui est totalement linverse
d'apocalypse ensuite nous avons le cas
de cyborg
le sauvetage est encore un point
d'interrogation que lui même a du mal à
comprendre le père de ce dernier aurait
apparemment dompter la boîte mais sans
réussir à vraiment la maîtriser
cette dernière aurait sauvé victor pour
faire de lui le cyborg
et si justement la boîte avait choisi de
sauver ce dernier dans un but précis
et quand bien même les boîtes nous
montre linverse total de la création
vie avec ce sauvetage elles ont redonné
vie à victor et lyon redonner son libre
arbitre puisqu'il peut agir selon sa
guise selon sa conscience selon son
nouveau corps ce qui est totalement
l'opposé de l'équation antifi enfin le
cas de superman suite à la scène d'intro
qui m'a donné des frissons
le cri de superman a réveillé de boxe
sur les 3 et la troisième a permis la
résurrection du héros utile le réveil
traduit tout d'abord la porte ouverte
pour steppenwolf sur terre puisque le
gardien de la planète est mort mais le
fait de ranimer superman nous traduit
autre chose superman est un héros clé
pour l'univers du dc où la justice
league a besoin de lui pour vaincre
steppenwolf et dark side et dans le
nightmare darkseid réussi à le corrompre
pour en faire l'ennemi principal de la
planète par rapport à l'idée de
l'équation de vie il est possible que
les boks et choisi de sauver six borg et
superman pour donner une chance à la
terre de terrasser darkseid cyborg qui
peut se lier aux boks et les comprendre
superman qui est le seul à pouvoir
vaincre steppenwolf un cycle dark side
et dans la métaphore si elles sont liées
à l'équation anti vie il se pourrait
qu'elle soit aussi lié à l'équation de
la vie une équation qui du coup existe
bel et bien dans les comics étant donné
qu'elles sont manipulés par dark side et
stephan wolf les boîtes nous montre un
pouvoir qui traduit l'équation anti vie
la terraformation de la terre en
apocalypse les parades et mon messi
contrôlé par un être comme superman ou
sai borg
une sorte d'élu des boîtes les mother
box agissait en rapport avec l'équation
de la vie puisque dark side a été
vaincue par la terre il ya bien
longtemps les mother box aurait pu
choisir d'aider la terre et ses héros
cette idée reste un petit peu farfelue
mais permettrait de créer un équilibre
entre le bien et le mal
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
évidemment toutes les théories
proviennent de moi et ce trois théories
existe avant tout pour nous permettre de
faire un premier pas dans l'univers de
dc comics et accessoirement rendre
hommage aux merveilleuses sneijder kuyt
c'est très compliqué de prévoir l'avenir
de la licence surtout en sachant que le
sneijder kuyt n'est pas canon n'est pas
officiel et qu'en plus de ça les suites
ont été annulés c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi je n'ai pas pris en compte dans
la vidéo je compte sur vous pour me
faire des retours et surtout me dire ce
que vous avez pensé du sneijder kuyt
je suis loin mais très loin d'être
expert dc comics mais j'espère que nous
aurons une nouvelle occasion de reparler
de tout ça ensemble
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus c'est
très important et surtout à vous abonner
à la chaîne pour ne louper aucune des
prochaines vidéos écouter
c'était targue rock et que le lionheart
soit avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]